microservices architecture is a pattern
for organizing computer systems into
services that can scale with demand
back in the 1990's an internet company
would run a big monolithic program on a
server that the company maintained
on-premise to serve an increase in
traffic a popular company would simply
add more instances of the monolith
monolithic architectures do have some
positive features a monolith centralizes
the codebase so it is in one place
engineers can step through any part of
the code when they are debugging also
user requests that are completely served
by a monolith do not have to make many
calls across a network which reduces the
chance of Network failures most software
companies have their code in a monolith
today when those monoliths get big
problems can start to occur centralized
code leads to tight couplings that are
hard to break up if a program is too big
it will be impossible to run on a
typical machine internet giants in the
early 2000s began breaking up their
applications into services instead of
scaling the monolithic application a
service-oriented architecture could
scale the parts of an application that
were under load operating system
virtualization made service-oriented
architecture more economical one server
could host multiple virtualized
operating system instances and each of
those instances could run a service but
this also meant that engineers had to
manage more and more layers of
infrastructure the virtual machine hosts
the hypervisor layer and the hardware
itself failures became more complex
debugging got harder in 2006 Amazon Web
Services launched the Elastic Compute
cloud ec2 allows programmers to rent
virtual machines in Amazon's data
centers with Amazon taking care of
failures at the hardware level
and the hypervisor level programmers
could focus on the virtual machine hosts
themselves where their application code
was running but using an entire virtual
machine to run a small piece of
application code is wasteful containers
allow a virtual machine to be sliced up
into isolated filesystem regions a
container can be as large as the entire
VM or as small as your smallest service
hence the term micro services micro
services run in containers which run on
a virtual machine which runs on a
hypervisor which runs on a server which
sits in Iraq which sits in a data center
which is part of a network of data
centers called the cloud containerized
architecture it led to a new problem
companies that ran thousands of micro
services in containers on the cloud did
not have a simple way of managing them
kubernetes is an open source project
from Google that gives engineers a
centralized system for managing
containers kubernetes also makes those
services portable creating a competitive
tension between Amazon Web Services and
Google cloud platform both of which can
host kubernetes clusters the days of
micro services are just getting started
software development has never been
easier and the two biggest companies in
the cloud are competing for users it's
going to keep getting easier and cheaper